how are you feeling about saying goodbye
to drugs it's bittersweet and
like roll
[Music]
I want you all to know that I'm grateful
for your
careers you can have
friends the people that are involved in
this film are family to me I love them
deeply but I feel like you know all
things must end and also you know
there's still things that I want to
accomplish I've done seven films as
tracks and so people a lot of times that
people don't think about that but when
you think about seven films as one
character I mean it's a lot it's a lot I
feel like it's come full circle and it's
time to to let go but it's a you know it
just stinks a little bit the trailer
made me cry it's a heartwarming film you
know which I think is the great thing
about James is he puts he always puts
heart into his film even as silly as it
may be here they may be fun or
ridiculous at times but there's always
just an emotional heartbeat to his films
and there's always an inspiring message
to his films and I love that about him
and I love that I love his films it
won't kill anyone who gets in our way no
not kill anyone kill a few people kill
no people kill one guy one stupid guy
who no one loves now you're just making
it sad do you see yourself going over to
DC at some point like a lot of people
think you're gonna play pain no I mean I
did Lobby forever but I think that James
and Peter are really smart in a way
they're just kind of rebooting
everything I think they're gonna reboot
fresh and with younger people who can
carry on for the next 10 years and that
wouldn't be me do you want to do that
again not that I don't want you I just
don't see myself in front of the camera
for another 10 years and I don't see
like to play the role of Bane I would
have to it would be physically demanding
so are you okay back to die with your
city
foreign
at this point I don't know if I'd do
justice to the role anymore so I would
steer away from it because I feel like
Bane deserves to be played by someone
who can be all in and I don't honestly I
don't know if I could be the four of us
are here
to prevent the Apocalypse
your family hasn't chosen to make a
horrible decision
if you fail to choose
a world went this is so great I love
this movie I love you in it thank you
it's just a different performance for me
it's uh it's you know I've been saying
all these years that I wanted to be an
actor and not a movie star I could care
less about that and this was kind of my
real chance to prove it you know in a in
a leading role it was a something of
this magnitude this way so that's it
it's just and I have a lot of anxiety
about it because now I have to you know
now I'm about to be judged but I've been
saying in all these years I just I want
to be respected as an actor do you go
online do you read reviews I try not to
I I've read a couple bad ones that
really stuck with me and I took
personally so I tried just just stay
away from it because I you know I think
it's always easier you know to really
absorb those negative things and they
kind of stick with you rather than you
know they could be a thousand positive
things and just one negative thing and
you harp on that one negative thing
and so I you know I just don't yeah I
tried I try and stay away from it
there's a lot of praise for this
performance and for you I love it and
also you know I hate to even say this
but I'm a little uncomfortable with
praise as well
you know I hope people love it but I
also at the same time it's just I really
want to be respected as an actor and so
this is I just put a lot of stock into
this performance how do you describe
working with M Night how does that
differ from anything you've done before
you know the thing is it's just such a
different process it's you know
typically what directors you get you
know you get minimal Direction you get
like a point here there or say you know
maybe say this word differently say it's
just in kind of a different direction
dialogue but with night it's it's so
funny and everybody you'll talk to the
cast and they'll all say the same thing
but he comes out and he sits down and
he's got this notebook and he opens up
the notebook
and he literally he gives you so much
information a process and they're not
just particular points but they're like
full on conversations about emotions and
about what the characters thinking what
his background might have been just a
very lengthy conversation so it's just
it's a lot to process and put into this
performance but it's also you know it's
something that I I love about him he's
such a loving giving caring person that
you know you kind of Welcome these
conversations and you want to have them
because you know that he's going to
bring out the best in you as a performer
how much do you dive into your
character's backstory because we're with
them for you know 24 hours or whatever
it is how much do you go into their past
I'm not one of those actors that dives
deeply into their past I just need to
know kind of what their nature is what
is short you know what kind of a short
synopsis of their background is and so a
lot of times I'll just you know kind of
you know if I don't have the
conversation with the director I'll just
make something up in my head so you know
I feel or kind of explain why I look a
certain way or you know why a character
like Leonard would be so large and why
he would be coaching kids other there
can I talk to you for a little bit
we're talking about
can you open the door please of course
she was an athlete you know maybe a pro
athlete or maybe someone who aspired to
be a pro athlete but just couldn't make
it just wasn't good enough but yeah just
simple things like that it's a
sweetheart yeah that's what I like about
this movie is like there's really not
like a villain everybody is like pure
and I think that's you know that's what
people are gonna struggle with this
because it is really for you know well
at least three very good people kind of
struggling to do what they feel like
they're being forced to do but they feel
like it you know it's for a greater good
it's uh you know it's a sacrifice that
they're making do you have a favorite of
my Java Movie 6 six times yeah yeah I
see dead people but I think it's six
cents I don't I will always lean towards
that you're talking about you know I
want to be an actor not a movie star
what does that look like to you like
what do you feel like your next steps
are our goals are you know I obviously I
have some things that are already on the
table and I have some obligations but my
end game is just to be a filmmaker just
to be you know producing hopefully
directing uh and I just want to continue
to be a Storyteller that's kind of
something I fell in love with throughout
wrestling and I feel like it
transitioned over into films and I love
just telling inspiring stories
foreign
[Music]